Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. I can't spell it right. So you just give a fake name, your cafe name, Julia. But the more you use it, the more it feels like you're in witness protection. Wait a minute. What kind of espresso drinks does Julia like anyway? Is it too late to change your latte order? But with an espresso machine by KitchenAid, you wouldn't be thinking any of this because you could have just made your espresso at home.
感谢收听《历史的 rest is history》。每周都有独家加更节目、无广告收听、抢先体验系列节目，并可加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区。请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。我总是拼错。所以你只要随便报个假名，比如你咖啡店的名字，茱莉亚。但你用得越多，就越觉得自己在接受证人保护。等一下。茱莉亚到底喜欢哪种意式浓缩咖啡？现在改点拿铁还来得及吗？不过，如果你有一台 KitchenAid 的意式浓缩咖啡机，你就不会有这些烦恼了，因为你在家就能自己做意式浓缩咖啡。
Shop now at KitchenAid.ca. Late October, A.D. 130. The body of a young man, still not twenty, was found floating in the Nile. Hauled out from the river, dragged through the silt left by the retreating floodwaters, the corpse was brought to dry land. It was clear that the drowned man had been a figure strikingly out of the ordinary. His body was gym-toned. His proportions were perfect.
立即前往 KitchenAid.ca 选购。公元 130 年十月下旬。一具年轻男子的尸体被发现漂浮在尼罗河面上，当时他还不到二十岁。尸体从河里被打捞上来，拖过退去的洪水留下的淤沙，带上了岸。显而易见，这个溺水身亡的男子绝非寻常之辈。他身材健美，比例完美。
His face possessed a heart-stopping, almost supernatural beauty. Who was he? A foreigner, clearly. Yet the stretch of the Nile in which he had drowned was hardly the haunt of glamorous foreigners. Alexandria lay far to the north. Although there was an ancient temple adorned with squat pillars and the carvings of a forgotten pharaoh looming
他的面容具有一种摄人心魄、近乎超自然的绝美。他是谁？显然是个外国人。然而，他溺水的这段尼罗河，却绝不是那些迷人的外国游人常去的地方。亚历山大城在遥远的北方。尽管那里有一座古老的寺庙，耸立着粗矮的石柱，刻有被遗忘的法老的浮雕，
over the waters in which the young man had drowned, the building did not feature prominently in the roster of Egypt's tourist attractions. Nothing stood beside it save a scruffy village. Yet here, to this obscure and rural spot, Caesar himself had come. Caesar, who ruled in Egypt as pharaoh, at once king and living god. His barge, together with a great flotilla of other vessels, stood moored in the shallows of the temple. Clearly then, the young man found in the Nile could only have been of his party. And so it proved. So that absolutely brilliant prose, Tom, which is from your forthcoming book, Pax. This is absolutely not the third time I've had to record this sentence because you were displeased with
俯瞰着年轻人溺水的河水，但这座建筑在埃及的旅游景点名册上并不起眼。除了一个破落的村庄，它旁边什么也没有。然而，凯撒本人却来到了这个偏僻的乡野之地。凯撒，这位作为法老统治埃及的人，集国王与活神于一身。他的巨型驳船连同其他许多船只的庞大船队，停泊在寺庙的浅水区中。显然，在尼罗河中发现的这个年轻人，只能是他随行人员中的一员。事实也的确如此。所以，汤姆，这段绝对精彩的散文出自你即将出版的新书《帕克斯》（Pax）。这绝对不是我第三次录制这句话，绝不是因为你对
the original iterations. I want nothing but the best for the listeners. I want them to know that Pax is now available for pre-order in the UK. But this is not about advertising. This is about a dramatic episode in history. Listeners can draw their own conclusions. Tom, tell us about the mystery. Make the mystery sound exciting so people will buy your book as you're so keen for them to do. Dominic, it's not about buying books. It's about marking Pride Month, which is happening in the UK at the moment and has become almost like a kind of religious carnival. So we're doing two episodes. The next one is going to be on Oscar Wilde, who is a martyr. But today we are looking at a god, because the young man who has been found
最初的版本不满意。我只想把最好的一切献给听众。我想让他们知道《帕克斯》现在已经在英国开启预售了。但这与广告无关，这是一个历史上的戏剧性事件。听众可以得出他们自己的结论。汤姆，给我们讲讲这个谜团吧。把谜团讲得刺激一点，这样大家就会像你那么渴望的那样去买你的书。多米尼克，这跟买书无关。这是为了纪念骄傲月（Pride Month），英国目前正在庆祝这个节日，它现在几乎变成了一种宗教狂欢。所以我们要制作两期节目。下一期将讲述奥斯卡·王尔德，他是一位殉道者。但今天我们要寻找的是一位神，因为在尼罗河水中被发现的那个年轻人
floating in the waters of the Nile is indeed of Caesar's party. And Caesar is the emperor Hadrian. And Hadrian will be so devastated by the loss of this young man that he makes him into a god. And so there are all kinds of mysteries that surround this episode. I mean, most obviously, how has he drowned? What's happened to him? But also what is the nature of his relationship with Hadrian and what is it about him? The cult of this young man, a Greek by the name of Antinous, becomes hugely successful. What is it about him that makes him such a striking figure? Right. So it's not just one of the great Roman mysteries, it's one of the great Roman love stories. Or is love story the right description? Well, we can discuss that.
漂浮着的年轻人确实是凯撒随行人员中的一员。而凯撒就是皇帝哈德良。哈德良对这个年轻人的死悲痛欲绝，以至于将他奉为神明。因此，围绕这一事件有着各种各样的谜团。我的意思是，最显而易见的是，他是怎么溺水的？他身上发生了什么？但同时，他与哈德良的关系究竟是怎么样的？他又有什么独特之处？这个年轻人的崇拜——一个名叫安提诺斯的希腊人——变得极其成功。究竟是什么让他成为了一个如此引人注目的巨星？没错。所以这不仅是罗马最伟大的谜团之一，也是罗马最伟大的爱情故事之一。或者说，爱情故事是正确的描述吗？嗯，我们可以讨论一下。
So the setting is a kind of a heyday of the Roman Empire. And Hadrian, best known in Britain for his war, he becomes emperor in 117. He is famously the first emperor to wear a beard. Since the first kind of ruler of the Near east to wear a beard since the time of alexander the great because alexander the great obviously set the fashion for clean shaving yes but hadrian wears a beard and in doing this it exemplifies the twin aspects of his character because on the one hand a beard marks him out as a legionary as a common soldier and he is much loved by the legions he is a man who has served with them, who does everything that whatever he asks them to do, he will do it. And even though he's building his walls and his palisades and so on, he's doing this. They're not defensive measures. They're kind of expressions of contempt for the barbarians who lie beyond the realms of imperial spectacles. Yeah, basically what Hadrian is saying is that this world,
所以当时的背景可以说是罗马帝国的全盛时期。哈德良在英国以他的长城而闻名，他在公元 117 年成为皇帝。他最为人所知的是第一位留胡子的罗马皇帝。自亚历山大大帝以来近东第一位留胡子的统治者，因为亚历山大大帝显然掀起了剃须的风潮，是的，但哈德良留了胡子，通过这样做，他体现了他性格的双重性：一方面，胡子将他标榜为一名军团士兵，一名普通士兵，他深受军团的爱戴，他是一个与他们并肩作战、只要他们要求的任何事他都会去做的人。尽管他在修建城墙和栅栏等等，但他这样做，并不是防御措施。它们某种程度上是对帝国权力范围之外的野蛮人的蔑视。是的，哈德良基本上是在说，这个世界，
the world ruled by Rome is a great garden and anyone beyond it, not allowed entrance. So, you know, you're kind of beyond the pale. And the other aspect of Hadrian's beard is that it marks him out as a philosopher. And Hadrian is a great lover of Greek culture. As a young man, he was called Grytlas. This devotion to Greece and to Greek culture and to the Greek way of doing things is something that marks him out as very distinctive among Roman emperors. There hasn't been a Roman emperor who
由罗马统治的世界是一个美丽的花园，任何外人都不准进入。所以，你知道的，你有点像是被排除在外的。而哈德良留胡子的另一个方面是，它将他标榜为一个哲学家。哈德良非常热爱希腊文化。年轻时，他被称为格里特拉斯（Grytlas）。这种对希腊、希腊文化以及希腊行事方式的奉献，使他在罗马皇帝中显得非常独特。从来没有一个罗马皇帝
has been so nakedly Philhellenic as Hadrian. Funnily enough, Tom, that's something he has in common with Oscar Wilde, who we're going to be talking about next. Anyway, back to the story. Well, so the mention of Oscar Wilde brings us on to Antinous, because Oscar Wilde was also very keen on Antinous, whose image is, I mean, you know, there are almost 120 statues of him have survived. Crikey.
像哈德良那样毫不掩饰地热爱希腊文化。说来也巧，汤姆，这也是他和奥斯卡·王尔德的共同点，我们接下来就要谈到奥斯卡·王尔德。不管怎样，回到正题。嗯，提到奥斯卡·王尔德就把我们引向了安提诺斯，因为奥斯卡·王尔德也非常迷恋安提诺斯，后者的雕像——我的意思是，你知道的，现存关于他的雕像有近 120 座。天哪。
He's born in 110, 111. Yep. In a place called Bithynia, which is the northwest of what is now Turkey. A place called Claudiopolis, which is mostly famous for its cheeses. Really? The thing about him is that he is stupefyingly gorgeous. And I went to an exhibition in Nottingham devoted to his statues, to his busts and so on. And a very famous bust of him got sent from Paris, from the Louvre. And when the curator
他出生于公元 110、111 年。没错。在一个叫做比提尼西亚（Bithynia）的地方，也就是现在土耳其的西北部。一个叫做克劳狄奥波利斯（Claudiopolis）的地方，那里最出名的是它的奶酪。真的吗？关于他，最重要的一点是他美得惊为天人。我去诺丁汉看了一个专门展出他的雕像、胸像等的展览。有一尊非常著名的他的胸像从巴黎的卢浮宫运了过来。当策展人
opened the crate, she saw that there were lipstick marks all over the marble lips of Antinous. So he is to this day capable of exciting, strong feeling. Members of the curatorial classes had been snogging the bust of Antinous. That absolutely confirms all my darkest fears, Tom, about curators. So he is celebrated as the most beautiful young man that anyone has ever seen. Everybody admits this. And Hadrian loves him for that, but loves him as well because he seems to have been very intelligent, very smart.
打开木箱时，她看到安提诺斯的大理石嘴唇上布满了口红印。所以直到今天，他依然能够激发出强烈的情感。策展界的人竟然一直在亲吻安提诺斯的胸像。这完全印证了我对策展人最黑暗的恐惧，汤姆。因此，他被誉为人们见过的最美丽的年轻人。所有人都承认这一点。哈德良爱他也正是因为这一点，但也因为他似乎非常聪明、机智。
And again, Hadrian himself inscribes this. He says that his heart was wise, his intelligence, that of a grown man. So how does Hadrian come across Antinous? Well, so Hadrian is a great traveler. I mean, that's what he's doing in Britain. He goes all across the empire. And he is in Claudiopolis in Bithynia in 123. And it's likely that he, so Antinous would have been 13 at this age. Hadrian seems to have talent spotted him. But Hadrian's almost 50 at that point, Tom. Hadrian is, yes, yes, by Roman standards, quite elderly by this point.
同样，哈德良自己也对此有碑文记载。他说安提诺斯拥有一颗睿智的心，有着成年人的智慧。那么哈德良是如何遇到安提诺斯的呢？嗯，哈德良是一个大旅行家。我的意思是，这就是他在英国要做的事。他走遍了整个帝国。公元 123 年，他在比提尼西亚的克劳狄奥波利斯。当时安提诺斯大概 13 岁，很有可能就是在那时，哈德良相中了这位少年。但汤姆，那时候哈德良已经快 50 岁了。哈德良是，是的，是的，按照罗马的标准，这时候他已经相当老了。
Hadrian seems to have sent him to Italy to be educated, be given schooling. And when Hadrian comes back to Rome, he seems to have become very, very devoted to Antinous and starts to take him with him on his travels. So late 128, he goes traveling once again, and he is going off with Antinous and also with his wife Sabina, with whom relations are perhaps understandably a little bit tetchy. And they go to Greece, and Hadrian spends a fair while there in Athens. He goes with Antinous to Eleusis, to the great mysteries. And these mysteries are about death and resurrection, about winter and summer, the idea that eternal life can be won. This is seen as the great gift of Athens to the world. So the fact that Hadrian shares these mysteries with Antinous is a kind of extra bond
哈德良似乎把安提诺斯送到意大利去接受教育和学校培训。当哈德良回到罗马时，他似乎对安提诺斯变得非常非常深情，并开始在旅行中带着他。所以在公元 128 年末，他再次踏上旅程，与安提诺斯同行，还有他的妻子萨比娜（Sabina），他和萨比娜的关系可能正如人们可以理解的那样，有点紧张。他们去了希腊，哈德良在雅典待了相当长的一段时间。他和安提诺斯一起去了埃琉西斯（Eleusis），去参加伟大的密特拉秘仪（mysteries）。这些秘仪关乎死亡与复活、冬日与夏日，以及能够赢得永生的理念。这被视为雅典对世界的最伟大馈赠。因此，哈德良与安提诺斯分享这些秘仪，在他们之间建立了一种额外的羁绊，
between them, I think. And Hadrian sets up this kind of Greek equivalent of the European Union called the Panhellenion. It's this kind of confederation of Greek cities with its headquarters in Athens. And it's all expressive of the way that Hadrian is devoted to the ideal of Greece. Can I just ask you a quick question at this point? What do people in Rome think about all this carrying on in Greece and wearing beards and stuff? Are they okay with it? They just think, well, the emperor's the boss, so fine, let him crack on. Or are some people muttering and saying, this is all a bit weird? There are definitely conservative Romans who dislike it. And I think the most eminent of these is Tacitus, who's-
我认为是的。哈德良建立了一种类似于欧洲联盟的希腊版本，叫做泛希腊同盟（Panhellenion）。这是一种希腊城市的联合体，总部设在雅典。这一切都表达了哈德良对希腊理想的奉献精神。我能在这个时候问你一个简单的问题吗？罗马人对在希腊发生的这些乱七八糟的事情、留胡子之类的事情是怎么看的？他们觉得没问题吗？他们只是觉得，好吧，皇帝是老大，那就随他去吧。还是有些人私下嘀咕，觉得这一切有点诡异？绝对有保守的罗马人不喜欢这样。我认为其中最杰出的人物就是塔西陀（Tacitus），他——
As in friend of the show, Tacitus. The great historian of early imperial Rome. And I think his portrait of Tiberius, which is of a Greek culture-loving autocrat who ends up murderous and depraved, is a kind of vicious pen portrait of Hadrian, actually. I think that is- Really? is a kind of vicious pen portrait of Hadrian, actually. I think that is. Yeah, I think so. But the Roman Empire has changed. It's becoming very, very multicultural. Greeks are entering the Senate. They're becoming consuls. The sense that this is becoming a Greco-Roman world is a wave that Hadrian is surfing. Of course, it generates grumbles in Rome, but not grumbles that are in any way threatening to him. The Greeks love him. Understandably, imagine that.
也就是节目的老朋友，塔西陀。早期罗马帝国的伟大历史学家。我认为他对提比略（Tiberius）的画像——一个热爱希腊文化的独裁者，最终变得残暴和堕落——实际上是哈德良的一个恶毒的文字肖像。我认为那是——真的吗？实际上是哈德良的一个恶毒的文字肖像。我认为是的。是的，我也这么认为。但罗马帝国已经变了。它变得非常非常多元文化。希腊人开始进入元老院。他们成为了执政官。这种世界正在变成一个希腊-罗马世界的趋势，正是哈德良正在顺应的潮流。当然，这在罗马引发了一些抱怨，但这些抱怨绝不会对构成对他的威胁。希腊人爱戴他。可以理解，想象一下吧。
He arrives in Alexandria, and he has Antinous with him. For the Greeks in Alexandria, as in Athens, the fact that he has this Greek of Greek lover with him is taken as a marker of Hadrian's respect for their entire culture. And by the time that they reach Alexandria, which is in 130, Antinous is 19. So he's putting on muscles. He's starting to get hairs on his chin. He's starting to look the kind of lad who would go out and engage in a lion hunt. And that's exactly what they do. Hadrian and Antinous go out and they hunted a terrifying lion out in the desert. Hadrian commemorates this with portraits of great feet, and these end up on the Arch of Constantine in Rome. They were kind of reused. So we see this image of how Hadrian
他抵达亚历山大港，带着安提诺斯。对于亚历山大港的希腊人来说，正如在雅典一样，他带着这位希腊恋人，被视为哈德良尊重他们整个文化的标志。到了公元 130 年他们到达亚历山大港时，安提诺斯已经 19 岁了。所以他正在长肌肉。他的下巴开始长出胡须。他开始长成那种会出去参加狩猎狮子的少年。而这正是他们所做的。哈德良和安提诺斯外出，在沙漠中猎杀了一头可怕的狮子。哈德良用巨大的足迹画像来纪念这一壮举，这些画像最终出现在罗马的君士坦丁凯旋门上。它们被某种程度上重复使用了。所以我们看到了这种图像，关于哈德良如何
saw Antinous in what becomes the last year of his life. You know, it survives, kind of like photographic snaps almost. You used the phrase a few paragraphs ago, his Greek lover. Is that how everybody perceives them? They don't just think favourite, cupbearer, you know, they think lover. They think lover and they think Greek. And both of those are very important. We'll come to why they're important later on.
在他生命的最后一年看待安提诺斯。你知道的，它保存了下来，几乎就像照片快照一样。你在前几个段落里用过这个词，他的希腊恋人。这就是所有人对他们的看法吗？他们不只是认为他是受宠者、斟酒侍者，你知道的，他们认为他是恋人。他们认为他是恋人，而且他们认为他是希腊人。这两点都非常重要。我们稍后会谈到为什么它们很重要。
But just to continue the story of Antinous' life, because it's very, very short. That year of 130, where he's come to Alexandria, they've had the lion fight. Then they go on a Nile cruise. And they're going down the Nile. And this great festival of the god Osiris is being marked. And what it's commemorating is, people may remember the story, Osiris is married to his sister Isis. They have a brother Typhon, or Seth as it was, but Typhon in the Greek version. And Typhon attacks Osiris, kills him, puts him in a coffin, chucks him into the Nile.
但为了继续安提诺斯的生活故事，因为他的生命非常非常短暂。在公元 130 年那一年，他来到了亚历山大港，他们进行了狮子之战。然后他们去进行尼罗河巡游。他们顺流而下尼罗河。欧西里斯神（Osiris）的盛大节日正在举行。人们可能还记得这个故事，欧西里斯与他的妹妹伊西斯（Isis）结婚。他们有一个兄弟提丰（Typhon），或者说是塞特（Seth），但在希腊版本中是提丰。提丰攻击欧西里斯，杀死了他，把他装进棺材，扔进了尼罗河。
The anniversary of this is commemorated on the 24th of October, so the last week of October. And it's in the last week of October that Antinous is found drowned in the Nile. So he's been thrown into the Nile or perished in the Nile exactly as Osiris did. And so it's a kind of very haunting scene because on the festival of Osiris, the Nile is ablaze with small ships with lamps on them and you have music and revelry floating from the shores yeah so kind of very very dramatic setting for this this accident if it's an accident or murder we you know we'll come and discuss perhaps what has happened but what we know for sure is that
这一事件的周年纪念是在 10 月 24 日，也就是 10 月的最后一周。正是在 10 月的最后一周，安提诺斯被发现溺死在尼罗河中。所以他被扔进尼罗河或在尼罗河中丧生，就像欧西里斯一样。因此这是一个非常令人难忘的场景，因为在欧西里斯节期间，尼罗河上闪烁着装有灯的小船，河岸上飘荡着音乐和狂欢，是的——所以这是一个非常非常戏剧化的背景，如果是意外的话，或者如果是谋杀的话，你知道的，我们稍后会来讨论发生了什么，但我们确定的是，
hadrian is devastated we're told that he weeps like a woman, which is for the Romans a pejorative. And he's absolutely prostrated, but then he has a vision. Antinous appears to him in a dream and announces his resurrection. And in the sky, a new star appears and astrologers inform Hadrian that this is the soul of Antinous. And so Hadrian founds a city that he calls Antinopolis, the city of Antinous. And it's a Greek city, but at the heart of it, there is going to be an Egyptian temple devoted to a god called Osirantinous. So Osiris fused with Antinous. A syncretic god. A syncretic god. And messengers are sent across the Roman world informing people about this. And so they go across Egypt, they go to Greece, they go to Bithynia.
哈德良悲痛欲绝。据说他像女人一样哭泣，这在罗马人看来是一个贬义词。他彻底崩溃了，但随后他看到了异象。安提诺斯在梦中向他显现，宣告了自己的复活。天空中出现了一颗新星，占星家告知哈德良，这就是安提诺斯的灵魂。于是哈德良建立了一座城市，他称之为安提诺波利斯（Antinopolis），即安提诺斯之城。这是一座希腊城市，但在它的核心，将有一座埃及神庙，供奉着一个名为“欧西里安提诺斯”（Osirantinous）的神。也就是欧西里斯与安提诺斯的融合。一个融合神。一个融合神。使者被派往整个罗马世界，将这一消息通知人们。于是他们穿过埃及，前往希腊，来到比提尼西亚。
And this is Hadrian kind of acknowledging that Antinous is a multicultural god. He's from Bithynia. He's Greek. He's died in Egypt. He's arisen from the dead and has become fused with an Egyptian god. This is something that is not Roman. It's something that is bred of the kind of the eastern half of the empire, something very radically new, but sponsored by Caesar. And so to that extent, he is Roman as well. And so perhaps in that context, it's not surprising that his cult spread very, very rapidly. So I said that almost 120 statues of him have survived. And right the way into the present, there's a very famous photograph of a statue of him being discovered at Delphi. So you have kind of Victorian archaeologists all gathered around, and there is this naked figure emerging from the dirt.
这就像是哈德良在承认安提诺斯是一个多元文化之神。他来自比提尼西亚。他是希腊人。他死在埃及。他从死里复活，并与一个埃及神融合。这不是罗马本土的东西。这是帝国东半部孕育的东西，是非常激进的新事物，但由凯撒资助。因此从这个意义上说，他也是罗马人。所以在那种背景下，他的崇拜以极快的速度传播也就不足为奇了。所以我说过，现存关于他的雕像有近 120 座。一直到今天，都有一张非常著名的照片，记录了在德尔斐发现他的雕像的场景。你可以看到维多利亚时代的考古学家们聚集在一起，这个赤裸的身影从泥土中显露出来。
And so he becomes this icon of male beauty. That's why Oscar Wilde loves him. He compares him to Dorian Gray in his novel. And today he is celebrated as a gay god. There are people who kind of enshrine him as... There aren't people who worship him. I don't believe that. They do it in a spirit, perhaps, of kind of postmodern jouissance. But he's certainly a presence online as a gay god. So that's the backstory. And as I say, there are these kind
于是他成为了男性美的偶像。这就是为什么奥斯卡·王尔德如此喜爱他。他在小说中将他比作道林·格雷（Dorian Gray）。而今天，他被尊为同阳之神。有些人将他奉为……并没有人真的崇拜他。我不相信这一点。他们这样做，也许是出于一种后现代的狂欢（jouissance）精神。但他在网络上确实作为一个同性恋神而存在。这就是背景故事。而且正如我所说，周围悬挂着各种
of mysteries that hang around him. And I guess, I mean, moving in on that idea of him as a gay god, and we're doing this for pride, the question, is it simplifying things or are you running the risk of being anachronistic if you describe him as gay? So if you say, this is a homosexual relationship, is homosexuality an adequate word to convey the complexities of a relationship that belongs to a very, very different age. The word itself is 19th century, right? It's a 19th century word. So it's a little bit like saying, Julius Caesar conquered France to say that Antinous is gay. And kind of example of that,
谜团。我想，结合他作为同性恋神的这个概念，我们正在为骄傲月（Pride）做这期节目，一个问题是：如果你把他描述为同性恋，这是否是在简化问题，或者你是否有犯历史错误（anachronistic）的风险？所以如果你说，这是一段同性恋关系，同性恋（homosexuality）这个词是否足以传达一段属于一个非常、非常不同时代的复杂关系的全部内涵？这个词本身是 19 世纪的，对吧？这是一个 19 世纪的词。所以这有点像说儒略·凯撒征服了法国来形容安提诺斯是同性恋。这方面的一个例子是，
there's a book called Roman Homosexuality by a great scholar called Craig Williams, which is really the kind of the definitive work on this subject. And even though he's called his book Roman Homosexuality, he writes this in the introduction, to judge by the textual material left to us, homosexuality turns out not to have been an important issue for Romans, nor for that matter was heterosexuality. Roman men were not encouraged by their cultural heritage to categorize, much less evaluate or judge, sexual acts and agents on the basis of whether only males or males and females were involved. So what he means by that is basically that for us,
有一本书叫做《罗马同性恋》（Roman Homosexuality），作者是一位伟大的学者克雷格·威廉姆斯（Craig Williams），这真的是这个主题的决定性著作。尽管他把书名定为《罗马同性恋》，他在引言中写道：从留给我们的文本资料来看，同性恋对罗马人来说并不是一个重要的问题，异性恋同样也不是。罗马人的文化传统并没有鼓励他们根据性行为和参与者是仅有男性，还是同时有男性和女性，来对性行为和行为主体进行分类，更不用说去评估或判断了。所以他的意思是，基本上对我们来说，
gender is the kind of the key binary. So men and women, do you sleep with men? Do you sleep with women? That's how we define people. That's why homosexuality and heterosexuality are the two great dividing lines. But for the Romans, that wasn't the case. For the Romans, they understood, of course, that some men only wanted to sleep with women and that some men only wanted to sleep with men. So Suetonius in his Lives of the Caesars describes Claudius as a man who only ever slept with women and Galba as a man who only ever slept with men. But these are kind of interesting foibles in the way that we might say, well, a man only ever sleeps with blondes or with brunettes. It's an interesting sexual foible,
性别是关键的二元对立。所以男人和女人，你和男人睡觉吗？你和女人睡觉吗？这就是我们定义人的方式。这就是为什么同性恋和异性恋是两条伟大的分界线。但对罗马人来说，情况并非如此。对于罗马人来说，他们当然知道有些男人只愿意和女人睡觉，有些男人只愿意和男人睡觉。因此，苏埃托尼乌斯（Suetonius）在《罗马十二帝王传》中将克劳狄乌斯描述为一个只和女人睡觉的人，而将加尔巴（Galba）描述为一个只和男人睡觉的人。但这些只是有趣的怪癖，就像我们可能会说，某个男人只和金发女郎或黑发女郎睡觉一样。这是一种有趣的性癖好，
but it's not the defining characteristic. And it doesn't have a moral charge? It doesn't have a moral charge at all. Although that's not to say that there isn't a moral charge around sex, which we'll come to fairly soon. So basically, what Hadrian is doing, sleeping with a beautiful young man, there's no pejorative sense attached to that at all. So if you think of Vitellius, another of the four emperors, he has a similar relationship to a young man called Asiaticus, who is his slave. And Vitellius becomes obsessed by him, is devoted to him in exactly the way that Hadrian is devoted to Antinous. And this is remembered as a scandalous story. But it's a scandalous story because Vitellius frees his slave, Asiaticus, and then gives him all kinds of honors and raises him up to become one of his chief advisors. And this is felt as utterly demeaning and disgraceful and depraved.
但它不是决定性的特征。而且它没有道德负罪感？它完全没有道德负罪感。尽管这并不是说围绕性没有道德负罪感，我们很快就会谈到这一点。所以基本上，哈德良在做的事——和一个美丽的年轻人睡觉——完全没有附加任何贬义。因此，如果你想想维特利乌斯（Vitellius），另一位四帝之年的皇帝，他和一个叫亚西亚提库斯（Asiaticus）的年轻奴隶也有类似的关系。维特利乌斯对他着迷，对他全心全意，就像哈德良对安提诺斯那样。这被当作一个丑闻故事流传下来。但这是一个丑闻故事，因为维特利乌斯释放了他的奴隶亚西亚提库斯，然后赋予了他各种荣誉，把他提拔为自己的首席顾问之一。这被认为是非常有失体统、极其可耻和堕落的。
And so when Vitellius gets overthrown, Asiaticus gets captured and gets crucified as a slave. Right. Yeah, crucified. He gets crucified. But the reason why Vitellius is kind of, you know, this is seen as being disgraceful is because he is raising freedmen up to positions that they shouldn't properly have. There's this kind of sense of social dislocation. It's not the fact that Vitellius is having an affair with a young man. That's absolutely fine. The further dimension with Vitellius is that he is strongly suspected himself of having offered himself up to an emperor, namely Tiberius. So Vitellius' nickname throughout his life is Sphincter. Oh my God, what a nickname. That's not a nickname throughout his life is sphincter oh my god what a nickname
因此，当维特利乌斯被推翻时，亚西亚提库斯被俘虏，并作为奴隶被钉死在十字架上。没错。是的，被钉死在十字架上。他被钉死在十字架上。但维特利乌斯之所以被视为——你知道的，这被视为可耻，是因为他把释放的奴隶提拔到了他们本不应该担任的高位。这里有一种社会秩序混乱的感觉。并不是因为维特利乌斯和年轻人有染。那是完全没问题的。维特利乌斯的另一个层面是，他自己也遭到强烈怀疑，曾向一位皇帝（即提比略）献身。所以维特利乌斯一生中的外号是“括约肌”（Sphincter）。哦，天哪，多么响亮的外号。那不是——他一生中的外号是括约肌，哦，天哪，多么响亮的外号
that's not a nickname you choose is it what to the romans is shocking is not that and people who are listening with children might want to just turn the dial down at this point what is shocking for the Romans is not a man who forces himself on another male, but a man who offers himself up to another male. And so this is what Betelius, as a young man, is meant to have done. He's offered himself up to Tiberius to be used. So you don't want to be the passive party, as it were. You don't want to be the passive. And anyone who does that, the Romans have this concept of pudicitia. So a pudor is shame. A pudicitia is your sexual integrity,
那不是你自己选的外号，对吧？对罗马人来说，令人震惊的不是这个——带着孩子的听众现在可能想把音量调小一点——对罗马人来说，令人震惊的不是一个强迫另一个男性的人，而是一个向另一个男性献身的人。所以这就是维特利乌斯年轻时被认为做过的事。他向提比略献身以供其玩弄。所以你可不想成为被动的一方，对吧？你不想成为被动的一方。任何这样做的人，罗马人有一个概念叫做 pudicitia。pudor 是羞耻。pudicitia 是你的性节操，
your bodily integrity. And if you lose that, or if you are thought to have lost it, then that is a taint that endures for the rest of your life. And the word that is used for this kind of person, you are impudicus. So you are someone who lost your modesty, you've lost your sexual integrity, or you're apathicus, you're passive. But Tom, what about women? Where do they fit into this? Basically, the binary in Roman sexuality, and to our way of thinking, I think it's quite a brutal one, is that there are those who force themselves on other human beings and there are those who are forced. And women rank with passive men or boys as those who do not force themselves on people. And the person who is allowed to force himself on other people
你的身体完整性。如果你失去了这一点，或者如果人们认为你失去了这一点，那么这就是一个会伴随你余生的污点。用来形容这种人的词是，你是 impudicus。所以你是一个失去谦耻、失去性节操的人，或者你是 apathicus，你是被动的。但是汤姆，女性呢？她们在其中处于什么位置？基本上，罗马性观念中的二元对立——按照我们的思维方式，我认为这是一个相当残忍的二元对立——就是：有一类人强迫其他人类，还有一类人是被迫的。女性与被动的男人或男孩归为一类，即那些不强迫别人的人。而那个被允许强迫别人的人
is a free Roman citizen. And the penis is seen as being equivalent to the sword of the legions that has enabled Rome to conquer the world. But a powerful woman, so Calpurnia, Octavia, Livia. So it unsettles that. It unsettles that. But these people would still, despite their power and their general impressiveness, they would nevertheless be tainted by the fact that they were impudica, I suppose. No, they're not.
是一个自由的罗马公民。而阴茎被视为等同于使罗马征服世界的军团之剑。但是一个强大的女性，比如卡尔普尼娅（Calpurnia）、屋大维娅（Octavia）、莉维亚（Livia）。所以这动摇了这一点。这动摇了这一点。但这些人尽管拥有权力和普遍的威严，却仍然会因为她们是 impudica（不贞洁的）而受到玷污，我想是这样的。不，她们不会。
The wives of free citizens. So you're not allowed, as a Roman male, to force yourself, say, on free women. Oh, okay. Or other citizens. This is a crime called stuprum and is very, very rigorously patrolled. But the idea is that there are classes of people who are absolutely free game, of whom slaves are the absolute archetype. And essentially, one of the reasons why it is shameful for a Roman citizen to be an impudicus, apathicus, is basically because you are playing the role not just of a woman, but of a slave. The word that sums up basically
自由公民的妻子。所以作为罗马男性，你是不被允许强迫自己去侵犯自由女性的。哦，明白了。或是其他公民。这是一种被称为 stuprum 的犯罪，受到非常非常严格的监督。但其理念是，有一类人是绝对可以随意侵犯的，其中奴隶就是绝对的原型。从根本上说，罗马公民成为 impudicus（不贞洁者）或 apathicus（被动者）之所以可耻，主要是因为你扮演的角色不仅仅是一个女人，而且是一个奴隶。这个词概括了基本上
the idea of a man who wants to play the part of a woman, the word the Romans use for this is tinnitus. And you can be the passive partner in a gay relationship. That's what a tinnitus is keen on. But also it's a kind of broader idea that you are not playing the role of a woman, that you are, essentially, you are gender deviant, if you want to put it that way. Not playing the role of a man, you mean? Yeah. Sorry. Yeah. And so the word tinnitus seems to derive from a Greek word for a kind of dancer who shakes his buttocks. And so there's a connotation in that word tinnitus that it's youthful, it's Greek, it's Eastern, and it's servile. And this idea that to be a pathicus is also to be servile, the corollary of that is that anyone who is a slave is seen basically as being feminized, as being effeminate. And that in turn generates this kind of erotic dimension in which the great object of Roman desire throughout the first and second century is a young boy or young youth who
一个想扮演女性角色的男人的概念，罗马人使用的词是 tennitus。你可以在同性恋关系中扮演被动的一方。这就是 tennitus 热衷的事情。但这也是一种更广泛的观念，即你没有扮演女人的角色，而是本质上，如果你想这么说的话，你是一个性别越轨者。你是说没有扮演男人的角色？对。抱歉。是的。所以 tennitus 这个词似乎源于一个希腊词，指一种摇晃臀部的舞者。因此，在 tennitus 这个词中带有一种内涵，即它是年轻的、希腊的、东方的和奴性的。而“成为被动者（pathicus）也意味着具有奴性”这一观念的推论是，任何身为奴隶的人基本上都被视为被女性化了、被阉割般的柔弱。而这反过来又产生了一种色情维度，即整个第一和第二世纪罗马人心中渴望的伟大对象是一个小男孩或年轻少年，他
looks like a girl. So the word for this is a delicatus. And delicati are the most expensive kind of slaves that you can get. And they will have feminine hairstyles. They will wear makeup wear female clothing and these are absolutely prestige elite luxuries status symbols and basically the more of these you have and the more beautiful they are the more it redounds to your own prestige and status and that would go for your russell crowe you're an incredibly you know sweaty muscle-bound super macho general but you would nevertheless surround yourself with delicati because they are yeah well they're like having rolex watches or yeah and that these delicati would be glabry smooth-skinned effeminati i mean the word translates itself yeah they would you know you would invite your guests around and you would have them kind
看起来像个女孩。所以这个词叫做 delicatus。而 delicati 是你能买到的最昂贵的奴隶。他们会有女性的发型。他们会化妆，穿女性服装，这些绝对是声望极高的精英奢侈品、地位象征。基本上，你拥有这种奴隶越多，他们越漂亮，就越能彰显你自己的威望和地位。这一点对罗素·克劳这样的人也适用——你是一个极其、你知道的，满身大汗、肌肉发达、超级大男子主义的将军，但你仍然会周围环绕着 delicati，因为他们是——好吧，他们就像拥有劳力士手表或者——这些 delicati 会是无毛的（glabry）、皮肤光滑、女性化的（effeminati），这个词本身就能说明问题——是的，你会邀请你的客人们来家里，让他们装饰你的晚宴，每个人都会知道你极其富有。这就是为什么我们有一段时间没有在《历史的 rest is history》中聊到太监了。但在这里我们可以引入太监。这就是为什么在第一世纪，太监成为了一种特殊的声望地位象征。汤姆，你爱太监。我的意思是，毫无疑问。所以我们谈到了提比略。提比略是一个最终被推翻的中尉。
of adorning your dinner party and everyone would know that you're incredibly rich. And so this is why we haven't had eunuchs on the rest of history for a while. But here we can introduce eunuchs. This is why eunuchs in the first century become particular kind of prestige status symbols. Tom, you love eunuchs. I mean, there's no doubt about that. So we talked about Tiberius. Tiberius is a lieutenant who ends up kind of being overthrown by Tiberius.
塞扬努斯（Sejanus），在历史记载中他总是显得有些单调、沉闷。尽管如此，老普林尼（Pliny the Elder）还是提供了这样一个令人难以置信的细节：他买下了史上最昂贵的奴隶，那是一个名叫派松（Paison）的太监，基本上就是男宠。我的意思是，翻译过来就是这样。一笔难以置信的巨款。但最著名的太监，那个将“男孩可以被女性化”这一理念推向极致的人，当然是斯波鲁斯（Sporus）。《历史的 rest is history》的老朋友。
Ser Janus, who always seems a slightly drab, dull figure in the accounts. Nevertheless, Pliny the Elder gives this incredible detail that he bought the most expensive slave of all time, which was a eunuch called Paison, which is basically boy toy. I mean, that's how it translates. Incredible sum of money. But the most famous eunuch of all, the one that pushes this idea that a boy can be feminized is, of course, Sporus. A friend of the rest is history.
《历史的 rest is history》的老朋友。这个悲剧性的男孩被阉割，并被改造为尼禄死去的妻子波帕埃亚·萨比娜（Poppaea Sabina）的形象。而尼禄一如既往地将地位象征推向了绝对的极限。然而，当哈德良成为皇帝时，太监已经被刑事定罪了。你是不被允许拥有太监的。尽管图密善（Domitian）本人就拥有一个太监，但这仍然被视为极度虚伪。而且图密善本人就拥有一个。这被视为极度虚伪。图密善是一位非常注重细节的皇帝。当他禁止太监时，他立即对已经被阉割的奴隶的销售实行了价格管制，
Friend of the rest is history. This kind of tragic boy who gets castrated and transformed into the image of Nero's dead wife, Poppaea Sabina. And Nero, as ever, is kind of pushing status symbols to the absolute limit. However, by the time that Hadrian becomes emperor, eunuchs have been criminalized. You're not allowed to have eunuchs. And this is despite the fact that Domitian himself owned one. And so this was seen as the height of hypocrisy. And Domitian himself owned one. This was seen as the height of hypocrisy. Domitian is an emperor who has great attention to detail. When he bans eunuchs, he immediately imposes price controls on the sale of slaves who've already been made into eunuchs,
以防止投机倒把。这就是他那种注重细节的风格。但他这样做基本上是因为这被视为堕落。这违背了罗马道德。你不应该这样做。这是希腊人会做的事。所以，好吧。这里存在着一种紧张关系。存在一种既有的紧张关系。人们感觉到拥有这些——这仅仅指太监，还是也包括 delicati？换句话说——Delicati 是没问题的。Delicati 是没问题的。所以在某种程度上，太监有点像在作弊。如果你阉割了一个 delicatus 并让他保持年轻，那就被视为作弊。
so as to prevent speculation. That's the kind of attention to detail he has. But he's doing this basically because it's seen as being depraved. It's against Roman morality. You shouldn't be doing this. It's the kind of thing that Greeks do. So, okay. So there's a tension there then. There's a pre-existing tension. There's a sense that to have these, is it just eunuchs or does it include delicati as well? In other words- Delicati are fine. Delicati are fine. So in a way, eunuchs are kind of cheating. If you castrate a delicatus and you keep them young, that's seen as being cheating.
所以图密善引入这项法律基本上是为了阻止人们作弊。我的意思是，他认为这违背了罗马道德。这并不是因为他同情太监或男孩。因为他自己就有一个非常宠爱的太监，他还释放了他并扶持了他。所以他似乎确实有，也许其中包含某种成份。但我认为这并不是他这样做的原因。这意味着，当哈德良成为皇帝时，存在着一种需求。如果你能找到一个 delicatus 或者一个美得像太监一样的男孩，那显然就是终极梦想。基本上，这就是安提诺斯。我的意思是，安提诺斯不是奴隶。他是一个自由人，
So Domitian is introducing this law basically to stop people from cheating. I mean, he sees it as being against Roman morality. It's not because he feels sorry for the eunuchs, the boys. So he has a eunuch who he's devoted to and he frees him and sets him up. So he does seem to have, maybe there is an element of that. I don't think that's not why he's doing it though. And what that means is that by the time that Hadrian becomes emperor, there is a requirement. If you can find a Delicatus or a boy who is so beautiful that he looks like a eunuch, then that is obviously the dream. And basically that's what Antinous is. I mean, Antinous is not a slave. He's a free person,
但他不是公民。因此，从这个意义上说，按照罗马道德的标准，他是可以被随意对待的。这就解释了为什么所有人对安提诺斯都神魂颠倒，基本上也解释了为什么每个人都嫉妒哈德良，因为他身边有这么一个不可思议的男孩。太棒了。所以这就铺垫了一些背景故事，我们接下来会深入探讨安提诺斯，然后汤姆将——我非常兴奋地宣布，汤姆将解开这个谜团。我们喜欢解开谜团。我们喜欢解开谜团。是的。所以汤姆将解开谜团，你们必须在休息之后回来收听。现在改点拿铁还来得及吗？不过，如果你有一台 KitchenAid 的意式浓缩咖啡机，你就不会有这些烦恼了
but he isn't a citizen. And so therefore, to that extent, by the standards of Roman morality, he is free game. And it's that that explains why everyone swoons so heavily over Antinous and basically why everyone is jealous of Hadrian because he's got this incredible boy by his side. All right. Brilliant. So that's set up some of the backstory and we'll get more into the Antinous and then Tom will be, I'm very excited to say Tom will be solving the mystery. We love to solve a mystery. We love to solve a mystery. Yes. So Tom will be solving the mystery and you'll have to come back after the break. is it too late to change your latte order? but with an espresso machine by KitchenAid you wouldn't be thinking any of this
因为你在家就能自己做意式浓缩咖啡了。立即前往 KitchenAid.ca 选购。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde），我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman），我们共同主持《The Rest Is Entertainment》。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、娱乐圈八卦，在我们的问答环节中，我们将拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了会员俱乐部。
because you could have just made your espresso at home shop now at KitchenAid.ca I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club.
如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目以及抢先购买现场门票的特权，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的 rest is history》。我们正在讨论哈德良和安提诺斯注定悲剧的爱情故事。当然，如果你想了解更多信息，只需提前预定汤姆·霍兰德（Tom Holland）的《帕克斯》（Pax）即可。汤姆在前半部分感到心碎，心碎不已。
If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are talking about the doomed love story of Hadrian and Antinous. And of course, if you want to read more about this, you need merely pre-order Tom Holland's packs. Tom, who was gutted, gutted in the first half.
他觉得自己的书被低估了。没人能在这时候这么说，汤姆，所以非常感谢多米尼克，非常非常感谢，真的很感激。强行推销结束了，你一直在随心所欲地谈论太监，现在让我们来谈谈希腊属性，因为当然，关于安提诺斯，不仅在于他是一个——正如你所说的——delicatus，这种极具吸引力的年轻人，而且他也是希腊人，不是吗？这一定也是其中的一个维度。是的。所以我觉得实际上这里有两个维度。首先，在罗马的色情想象中，希腊人被视为具有特殊的吸引力。他们与香水、玫瑰以及各种
He thought his book had been undersold. No one can say this about this moment tom so thank you dominic very very much appreciated very much so hard sell over you've been talking about eunuchs as you want and now let's talk about greekness because of course the thing about antinous is not just that he is as as you said, a delicatus, this sort of incredibly attractive youth, but he's Greek as well, isn't he? And that must be a dimension to it. Yeah. So I think that actually there are two dimensions here. So the first is that in the Roman erotic imagination, Greeks are seen as being peculiarly attractive. They're associated with perfume, with roses, with all kinds of things that
希腊爱情诗中唤起的种种意象联系在一起，诸如此类。而希腊世界中被认为盛产美味年轻男奴的地区，是一个叫做“亚细亚”（Asia）的地区，也就是基本上现在的土耳其。因此，维特利乌斯的爱人亚西亚提库斯，就是指这个。当然，安提诺斯来自比提尼西亚，它位于亚细亚以北。所以他充满了那种气息。但给这种对希腊男孩的色情方法赋予一层尊严光环的，还有神话。因此，宙斯本人从天而降，将特洛伊王子伽倪墨得斯（Ganymede）带走，让他做自己的斟酒侍者。于是伽倪墨得斯成了天上的神仙。然后是赫拉克勒斯（Hercules），他是所有希腊英雄中最伟大的一个。故事说他在阿尔戈号（Argo）上，这是伊阿宋的船，阿尔戈英雄们乘坐这艘船穿过撞击岩（clashing rocks）进入黑海寻找金羊毛。在他们穿过
are evoked in Greek love poetry, all that kind of stuff. And the area of the Greek world that is seen as being particularly productive of delicious young slave boys is the region called Asia, which is again, basically Turkey. So Asiaticus, the beloved of Vitellius, that's alluding to. And of course, Antinous comes from Bithynia, which is north of Asia. So he is redolent of that. But further kind of giving an aura of dignity to this whole kind of erotic approach to Greek boys is mythology. So Zeus himself has descended from the heavens and taken Ganymede, who is a Trojan prince, to be his cupbearer. So Ganymede becomes an immortal in the heavens. And then there's Hercules, who is the greatest of all the Greek heroes. And the story goes that he is on the Argo, Jason's ship, which is going with the Argonauts through the clashing rocks into the Black Sea to get the golden fleece. And after they've gone
撞击岩并朝着博斯普鲁斯海峡前进之后，他们在比提尼西亚的一个地区停下来取水。赫拉克勒斯有一个男侍童叫做许拉斯（Hylas）。许拉斯去寻找水，发现了一个泉水，凝视着水面，水里有仙女。他美得无以复加，以至于仙女们伸出手把他拉进水里，让他永远留在那里做她们的——我想，大概是像塞扬努斯那样的男宠吧。赫拉克勒斯悲痛欲绝，放弃了与阿尔戈英雄同行，因为他只是在比提尼西亚的山脉中四处游荡，呼唤着许拉斯的名字，由于
through the clashing rocks and they're heading up towards the Bosphorus, they stop at a region in Bithynia where they go to get water. Hercules has a page boy called Hylus. Hylus goes up looking for water, finds a spring, gazes into the waters, and there are nymphs in the waters. He's so exquisitely beautiful that the nymphs reach up and pull him into the water and keep him there forever to be their, I suppose, their boy toy, like Sejanus. And Hercules is devastated and abandons going with the Argonauts because he just kind of roams the mountains of Bithynia calling out Hylus's name, absolutely distraught because
失去他而心碎欲绝。现在，这就是安提诺斯出生的地区。而哈德良受过高等教育，绝对会意识到安提诺斯来自许拉斯失踪、以及伽倪墨得斯被宙斯带到天上的地区。这带给他一种神话般的颤栗。我认为哈德良对希腊文化的这种赤诚热爱，是安提诺斯对他产生吸引力的另一个关键部分，因为它在某种程度上使他能够摆脱——至少看起来是这样——罗马性道德理解中那种残酷的动态。那种强者与弱者的观念，
he's lost him. Now, this is the region from which Antinous comes. And Hadrian, being highly educated, would absolutely be aware that Antinous has come from the region where Hylas was lost and where Ganymede was taken up by Zeus to the heavens. That gives him a mythological frisson. I think the fact that Hadrian is so devoted to Greek culture is another crucial part in the appeal of Antinous for him, is that it kind of enables him to escape, at least it seems to have done, this kind of brutal dynamic that you get in the Roman sexual understanding of morality. This idea that there's the powerful and the powerless,
他失去了他。现在，这就是安提诺乌斯出生的地区。哈德良受过高等教育，他绝对会意识到，安提诺乌斯来自许拉斯失踪、且伽倪墨得斯被宙斯带到天上的地区。这带给他一种神话般的颤栗。我认为哈德良对希腊文化的执着是安提诺乌斯吸引他的另一个关键部分，这在某种程度上使他能够摆脱——至少看起来确实如此——你在罗马性道德理解中常见的那种残酷的动态关系。这种存在强者与弱者的观念，
the strong and the weak, the active and the passive. Because Hadrian understands that for the Greeks, there is a different way of understanding same-sex relations. And the Romans generally get this. So there's a Roman scholar writes about that in Greece, it is the custom to praise a young man for taking plenty of lovers. So they recognize that sexual standards, sexual morality vary from region and country and civilization. There's contingent, not absolute. Absolutely, yes. And so for all these reasons, I think the fact that Antinous is Greek is a crucial part of what makes him precious to Hadrian. So he's conjuring up dimensions of myth, but he is also offering him what I think you could call love. And I think that he offers
强者与弱者、主动者与被动者。因为哈德良明白，对于希腊人来说，同性关系有一种不同的理解方式。罗马人通常也理解这一点。因此，曾有一位罗马学者撰文写道，在希腊，赞美一个年轻人拥有众多情人是习俗。所以他们认识到，性标准的规范、性道德因地区、国家和文明而异。它是相对的，而不是绝对的。完全赞同，是的。因此，基于所有这些原因，我认为安提诺斯是希腊人这一事实，正是他成为哈德良心头之宝的关键所在。因此，他不仅唤起了神话的维度，而且还向他提供了一种我认为可以称之为爱的感情。我认为他提供
him love in a way that perhaps the traditional standards of Roman sexual morality couldn't. But we can't possibly know, can we, whether that's the case? We can't, because we have very few details of this. All we can say is that Hadrian is devoted to Greek culture. He seems to have been devoted to Antinous, and the scale of his bereavement when Antinous dies seems expressive of something more than just a master who has lost a slave. There really does seem to be something deeply personal and emotional there. Again, I think that the readiness of Greeks to worship Antinous as a god in due course reflects a sense that Hadrian really did love Antinous and that by loving Antinous,
给他的爱，也许是传统的罗马性道德标准所无法给予的。但我们绝不可能知道事实是否如此，对吗？我们无从得知，因为关于这方面的细节极少。我们只能说，哈德良对希腊文化充满深情。他似乎对安提诺斯深情有加，而安提诺斯死时他的悲痛程度，似乎不仅仅表现为一个失去了奴隶的主人。那里确实存在着某种极其深刻的个人情感。同样，我认为希腊人日后准备将安提诺斯奉为神明，反映出这样一种感觉：哈德良确实爱安提诺斯，并且通过爱安提诺斯，
he was showing his respect for them as subject peoples. No Roman emperor had done this before. It's not conclusive. We can't know that for sure. But putting all those strands of evidence together, I would say that what we have here probably is a love story. Certainly, it's absolutely the case that never before had a Caesar added to the ranks of the immortals who was neither an emperor nor a member of an emperor's family. You were talking about it's a way to escape from the power dynamic that's there was there at roman sexual relations and so on to a degree because of course hadrian is an old man with a young man so hatred is the most powerful man in the roman world yeah with a boy i mean there's no two ways about it what we would now describe as a boy so does well this is obviously a massive question, but when we're telling this story, it's hard for us to escape our 21st century subjectivity
他展现了对作为被征服民族的希腊人的尊重。此前没有任何罗马皇帝这样做过。这并非定论。我们无法确凿地知晓。但把所有这些证据线索串联起来，我认为我们在这里看到的很可能是一个爱情故事。当然，毫无疑问的是，在此之前，凯撒从未将一个既不是皇帝也不是皇帝家族成员的人列入神明的行列。你刚才提到，某种程度上这是逃避罗马性关系中存在的权力动力学的一种方式，因为当然哈德良是一个老人，而安提诺斯是个年轻人，所以哈德良是罗马世界中最有权势的人，是的，和一个男孩在一起——我的意思是，毫无疑问，用我们现在的话说就是一个男孩。那么，这显然是一个巨大的问题，但当我们讲述这个故事时，我们很难摆脱21世纪的主观性，
and to see the power imbalance in it. So does that change the way we talk about it, Tom? Or do you think we have to talk about it through exclusively as the Romans would have talked about? The power imbalance for the Romans is not a problem. It's the whole point. Right. Okay. Right. That's the essence of it. And that's why it's so difficult for us to get a handle on the Roman erotic imagination. It's very unsettling for us. For us, the idea that the powerful prey on the powerless is shocking and horrific and disturbing and it's harvey weinstein or whatever absolutely so yes exactly or indeed the kind of the slight sense
去看清其中的权力失衡。汤姆，这会改变我们谈论它的方式吗？还是你认为我们必须完全从罗马人当时的角度来谈论它？对于罗马人来说，权力失衡不是问题。这正是关键所在。没错。好的。没错。这才是本质所在。正因如此，我们才很难掌握罗马人的情欲想象。这让我们感到非常不安。在我们看来，强者捕食弱者的想法是令人震惊、可怕和不安的，这就像哈维·韦恩斯坦（Harvey Weinstein）或诸如此类的人，绝对如此，是的，完全正确，或者说确实有一种
of squeamishness that people feel seeing leonardo di caprio who go out with you know an 18 year old yeah there is a kind of nervousness and anxiety about it but for the romans not at all and indeed for the greeks because the idea that a young man is kind of educated by being the beloved of an older man is seen as part of his moral intellectual erotic education but is there an age beneath which they don't go that it's really not right? If your young man, in inverted commas, is 12, 10, 8, does that start to create a problem? For a Roman slave owner, he can do what he likes. Correctly.
人们看到莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥（Leonardo DiCaprio）和你知道的18岁女孩约会时感到的那种轻微的忸怩作态，是的，确实有一种紧张和焦虑，但对于罗马人来说则完全没有，对于希腊人也是如此，因为年轻人通过成为年长者的爱人来接受教育，这被视为他道德、智力和情欲教育的一部分。但是，是否存在一个年龄下限，低于这个年龄就不太合适了？如果你的“年轻人”（加了引号的）是12岁、10岁、8岁，这会不会开始成为问题？对罗马奴隶主来说，他可以随心所欲。没错。
Boys, girls, it doesn't matter what their age, they are fair game. It's an incredibly different world. And the brutality of that, I think, is obviously shocking to us. But I think for the Greeks, there is a, you don't jump children. There are kind of rituals. There are age-centered dynamics in relationship between an older man. And there's kind of evidence that Hadrian sends Antinous when he is a child to Rome and then doesn't see him for several years and then comes back. So it's likely that the sexual relationship, if there is one, you know, again, we don't even know for sure that there's a sexual relationship. We have no,
男孩、女孩，年龄并不重要，他们都是合法的目标。这是一个极其不同的世界。我认为这种残酷性对我们来说显然是令人震惊的。但我认为对于希腊人来说，你不会对儿童下手。这里面有某种仪式。年长者与年轻人的关系中存在以年龄为中心的动态。有证据表明，安提诺斯在还是个孩子的时候就被哈德良送到罗马，然后好几年没见，接着又回来了。所以很有可能，如果存在性关系的话——你知道，再说一次，我们甚至无法确定到底有没有性关系，我们没有
as it were, hard evidence for that. But I mean, it's pretty likely, I would think, if there's a sexual relationship, then it begins when Antinous is around the age that in the Greek world is seen as being the proper age for a young man to become the beloved of an older man. seems to have found emotional sustenance in that relationship in a way that he certainly doesn't with his wife and he doesn't seem to have done with any other sexual partner concubine whatever yeah and i think that that explains the titanic scale of his grief and there seems to be a kind of almost conscious repudiation of roman standards because when he proclaims Antinous a god, he doesn't ask the permission of the Senate, which he's actually obliged to. It's the Senate who can proclaim the immortality of a mortal. He doesn't do that. He doesn't go to Rome to do it. He uses the world as his stage. He founds this city, Antinopolis, to be on the shores of Egypt, to be this great center of pilgrimage. He goes to Athens and he inaugurates games called the Antinea, where youths on the cusp of manhood.
确凿的证据。但我的意思是，我想这很有可能，如果有性关系的话，那么它开始于安提诺斯大约达到希腊世界视为年轻人成为年长者爱人的合适年龄的时候。他似乎在那段关系中找到了情感上的支撑，这是他在妻子身上绝对找不到的，他似乎也没有在任何其他性伴侣、妾室身上找到过，是的，我认为这解释了他那惊天动地的悲伤规模。这似乎是一种近乎有意识地对罗马标准的拒绝，因为当他宣布安提诺斯为神时，他并没有征得元老院的同意，而他其实是有义务这么做的。只有元老院才能宣告一个凡人永生。他没有这样做。他没有去罗马做这件事。他以整个世界为舞台。他建立了一座城市，安提诺波利斯（Antinopolis），位于埃及海岸，成为一个伟大的朝圣中心。他前往雅典，创立了被称为“安提诺亚”（Antinea）的运动会，正处于成年门槛上的年轻人在此竞技。
So just as Antinous had been when Hadrian starts taking him on his travels, they compete for athletic and artistic prizes. And he goes to Eleusis, where he and Antinous had shared in the mysteries, and he sponsors a similar series of contests. What's intriguing about what he does at Eleusis is that he erects a statue of Antinous as a divine physician, someone who is a healer of the broken, a comforter of the wounded. And what's interesting about that is that it reverberates back to the temple of Antinous in Antinopolis, where it's proclaimed that the divine Antinous listens to the appeals of those who invoke him and heals the sick among the needy poor. And so Antinous as a god is offering provincials in the eastern half of
正如哈德良刚开始带安提诺斯去旅行时安提诺斯的状态一样，他们为争夺体育和艺术奖项而竞争。他前往厄琉西斯（Eleusis），在那里他和安提诺斯曾共同参与秘密仪式，并赞助了一系列类似的比赛。他在厄琉西斯所作所为引人入胜之处在于，他竖立了一尊安提诺斯作为神圣医神的雕像，一个破碎者的治愈者，受伤者的安慰者。有趣的是，这与安提诺波利斯的安提诺斯神庙遥相呼应，神庙中宣称神圣的安提诺斯会倾听向他祈祷者的呼吁，并治愈贫困者中的病人。因此，安提诺斯作为神，向罗马帝国东半部的行省居民提供了一种安慰——
the Roman Empire, people who are conscious of their subjection by Rome, an image of someone who is like themselves. So when they look at Antinous, they are not seeing as they would with the statue of a Caesar, the statue of Augustus, or even a Hadrian. They're not seeing someone who is expressive of the might of Rome. They're seeing themselves. And more than that, they are seeing someone who can offer comfort to the weak and the sick. And the slave who became a god. The slave who becomes the god. And so it's not surprising that Christian authors, I mean, they don't like any pagan gods, but they peculiarly detest Antinous because they see Antinous as a kind of perverted parody of Christ. in his relationship with Hadrian and who offers comfort to the weak and to the sick and is a provincial not a Roman in a sense is fighting on the same terrain as as Christ that's going to say
那些意识到自己被罗马征服的人们，看到了一个与他们相似的形象。因此，当他们看着安提诺斯时，他们看到的不是凯撒、奥古斯都甚至哈德良雕像所展现的那种罗马的强大力量。他们看到的是他们自己。不仅如此，他们看到的是一个能够抚慰弱者和病人的人。这个奴隶成了神。这个奴隶变成了神。因此，基督教作家们对此并不感到惊讶，我的意思是，他们不喜欢任何异教神明，但他们对安提诺斯格外痛恨，因为他们认为安提诺斯是基督的一种扭曲的讽刺画，他与哈德良的关系以及他为弱者和病人提供安慰、他是一个行省居民而非罗马人，从某种意义上说，他在与基督相同的阵地作战，这就好比是
their market competitors their market competitors same people yeah absolutely and so that's that's why the Christians really hate Antinous and of course preserve you know incredibly useful details of his cult and his life because invariably we know about pagan gods because christians complained about them so interesting yeah people worshiping antinous do you think all the way through to the the triumph of christianity absolutely yeah yeah i mean so evidence for his cult has been found in i think over 70 over 70 archaeological sites, which is a lot. So he is a god who is genuinely adored. People aren't just doing it because Caesar has told them to.
他们的市场竞争对手。他们的市场竞争对手，同一群人，完全是这样。所以这就是为什么基督徒真的讨厌安提诺斯，并且当然保留了关于他的崇拜和生平的极其有用的细节，因为我们往往是通过基督徒对异教神的抱怨才了解到他们的。多么有趣啊，人们对安提诺斯的崇拜一直持续到基督教的胜利，绝对是的。我的意思是，有证据表明他的崇拜遍布我认为超过70个考古遗址，数量非常庞大。所以他是一个真正被人们崇拜的神。人们这样做不仅仅是因为凯撒命令他们这样做。
So a really fascinating and intriguing figure. And I mean, I do encourage people that listen to this who have never seen Antinous, just go and Google his name. The statues of him are really stunning i mean that kind of absolute archetypes of of male beauty but of course we are left with one last mystery to try and solve which is the question of how did he drown why did he drown the biggest mystery of all so come on tom we've assembled in the drawing room okay lay out the theories the the clues and so on. Okay. So death on the Nile. So there are various theories. Certainty is impossible. So I'm afraid I can't do a Poirot and reveal what definitely happened, but here are the options. So one is that it was an accident. This is what Hadrian himself claimed. Hadrian said he fell into the Nile and drowned. So that's one possibility.
所以这是一个非常迷人且耐人寻味的人物。我的意思是，我确实鼓励听这个节目的、从未见过安提诺斯的人去谷歌一下他的名字。他的雕像真的很震撼，我的意思是，那是男性美绝对的典型。然而，我们自然留下了一个最后的谜团需要解开，那就是他是如何溺水的？他为什么会溺水？这是最大的谜团。所以，来吧，汤姆，我们在客厅集合了，好吧，列出各种理论、线索等等。好吧。尼罗河之死。所以有各种理论。确定性是不可能的。所以恐怕我不能像波洛（Poirot）那样揭示究竟发生了什么，但以下是几种选择。其一是这是一场意外。这也是哈德良自己声称的。哈德良说他掉进尼罗河淹死了。所以这是一种可能性。
A more glamorous and sinister theory, which is proposed by a historian called Cassius Dio, probably drawing on earlier speculation, is that he was the victim of a sacrifice. So Suetonius has a story that Nero sought to prolong his life by offering up the life of a mortal to the gods of the underworld. This idea that an emperor, because Hadrian, as you pointed out, he's getting on by this point. He's increasingly sick, increasingly tired. The idea that Antinous is sacrificed to try and preserve Hadrian's life.
一个更具魅力且带有阴谋论色彩的理论由一位名叫卡西乌斯·狄奥（Cassius Dio）的历史学家提出，他可能借鉴了早期的猜测，即他是牺牲品的受害者。苏埃托尼乌斯（Suetonius）曾有一个故事，讲的是尼禄为了延长自己的寿命，将一个凡人的生命献给冥界之神。这种观点认为，因为如你所指出，哈德良此时已经上了年纪。他越来越虚弱，越来越疲惫。安提诺斯被作为牺牲品献出，以试图保住哈德良的生命。
And it is the festival of Osiris, right? Absolutely. So that is also a kind of crucial context for it, because Osiris is the god of the dead, who has risen up from death back to life. And so the coincidence, well, is it just a coincidence? I mean, lots of people have thought not. An alternative is that Antinous sacrifices himself. And again, that might play into his awareness of the special location, the special time, the fact that they're on the Nile, they're in the stretch of it where Osiris is meant
而且当时正是奥西里斯节（festival of Osiris），对吧？完全正确。所以这也是一个至关重要的背景，因为奥西里斯是死而复生的死神。那么这种巧合——好吧，这真的只是巧合吗？我的意思是，很多人认为并非如此。另一种可能是安提诺斯自愿献祭。同样，这可能与他对自己所处的特殊地点、特殊时间的意识有关，他们身处尼罗河畔，正是奥西里斯被认为
to have been thrown into the Nile, that he is offering himself up as a sacrifice to the gods to preserve the life of his beloved partner. I mean, that's another possibility. Another possibility is that Hadrian, who is by and large a man who keeps his emotions in check, but he's known to have the occasional fit of murderous rage. Perhaps Hadrian loses it and kills him, has his body dumped in the river. See, I like that, Tom, because that would explain the excessive grief. Yeah, the guilt.
被投入尼罗河的那段河段，他将自己作为祭品献给神明，以保住他深爱的伴侣的生命。我的意思是，这是另一种可能性。还有一种可能是，哈德良大体上是一个能克制情绪的人，但他偶尔也会大发雷霆。也许哈德良情绪失控杀了他，把他的尸体抛进河里。你看，我喜欢这个，汤姆，因为这可以解释他过度的悲伤。是的，内疚。
Yeah. Maybe Sabina, who is with Hadrian on this voyage, on this cruise. I mean, maybe she's jealous, kills him. Maybe somebody in the court is resentful of Antinous. I mean, Asiaticus is the kind of example of the hatred that a favourite is capable of generating. So maybe they get rid of him. And a final theory is that perhaps he doesn't die at all, but perhaps he's kind of fed up, jumps overboard and kind of swims away and lives in Alexandria. But over all of these theories hangs the fact that at the age of 19 or 20 by this point, he is not a eunuch. And so therefore he is losing the youthful bloom of his beauty. He's starting to bulk up, getting a bit of a beard.
是的。也许与哈德良同行的萨比娜（Sabina），也就是在这场航行中。我的意思是，也许她嫉妒，杀了他。也许宫廷里的某个人对安提诺斯怀恨在心。我的意思是，阿西亚蒂库斯（Asiaticus）就是宠臣所能引发的那种仇恨的一个例子。所以也许他们除掉了他。最后一个理论是，也许他根本没有死，也许他只是厌倦了，跳船游走并生活在亚历山大港。但在所有这些理论之上，悬着这样一个事实：此时他已经19岁或20岁了，他不再是一个阉人。因此，他正在失去青春美貌的光彩。他开始长胖，开始长胡子。
Is this a problem? Does he feel that it is more demeaning to be the passive partner, even of an emperor? He himself is becoming a man. So that again is a kind of possible psychological dimension to the story and we just can't know i mean we just don't know tom i know you're not going to want to do this but i'm going to try and get you to do it anyway pick one and it can just be your favorite it doesn't have to be i know we all know you don't know but come on what do you think so i think the fact that antinous is turning 20 and the fact that they are on the Nile at the time and at the place
这是一个问题吗？他是否觉得，哪怕作为皇帝的被动伴侣，也更加有失尊严？他自己正在成为一个男人。所以这再次成为故事中一个可能的心理维度，而我们无从得知。我的意思是，我们根本不知道，汤姆。我知道你不想这么做，但我还是要试着让你做：选一个吧，哪怕只是你最喜欢的，不需要——我知道我们都知道你不知道，但拜托，你认为呢？所以，我认为安提诺斯将满20岁这一事实，以及他们当时正身处尼罗河畔、身处
where this great festival of Osiris happens, I think it's entirely plausible that Antinous is upset about what's happening to his body, that he's devoted to hadrian this man who has cared for him and shown him the world and that he does offer himself up as a kind of sacrifice to try and preserve hadrian's life i'll be honest that is the count i would like to believe yeah i mean you know as i say we don't know but that's the account i like to believe believe because I think it dignifies both Antinous and Hadrian. Okay. I personally, listening to you lay out the theories, as is my want, I've gone for a much more undignified. I think they had a row.
奥西里斯盛大节庆发生的时间和地点这一事实，我认为完全合乎情理的是，安提诺斯对发生在自己身体上的变化感到沮丧，他全心全意地效忠于哈德良这个照顾他并带他看世界的男人，他确实将自己作为某种牺牲献出，试图保住哈德良的生命。说实话，这就是我愿意相信的说法。是的，我的意思是，正如我所说，我们并不知道，但这就是我愿意相信的说法，因为我认为这给了安提诺斯和哈德良尊严。好吧。我个人在听你陈述这些理论时，按照我的习惯，我选择了一个更没有尊严的。我认为他们吵了一架。
And he scrammed off. No, Hadrian hit him on the head with a pot or something. Yeah. Killed him and had him dumped in the river, yeah. I think the differences in our reading of the crime sum up the difference some of our characters so well our respective characters well you're more romantic aren't you more idealistic he did it he did it and he was right to do it whereas i'm a bit more banal let's be not at all you always you know i, I agree that's equally possible. Yeah. You've gone for the stuff of a proper, you know, a real...
然后他气冲冲地走了。不，哈德良用罐子之类的东西砸了他的头。对，杀了他是把他抛在河里，对。我认为我们对这起罪案的不同解读，很好地总结了我们各自性格的差异。你更浪漫，对吧？更加理想主义。他做了，他做了而且他认为是对的，而我则更加世俗。一点也不，你总是，你知道的，我同意这也是完全可能的。对。你选择了一个真正的、货真价实的……
I've gone for the sacral and the emotionally complex. Yes, I have. It's brilliant. Such an interesting story. Such an interesting story. I think it's really interesting because it simultaneously takes us into a completely different sexual world. And it reminds us of how contingent our attitudes to sex and gender are. And I think you can see why calling Antinous gay doesn't do justice to the complexity of what's going on. But at the same time, I think the, and again, it may be it's wishful thinking on my part. Maybe I am being overly romantic
我选择的是神圣且情感复杂的。是的，我确实如此。这太棒了。这是一个如此有趣的故事。一个如此有趣的故事。我认为它非常有趣，因为它同时把我们带入了一个完全不同的性世界，并提醒我们，我们对性和性别的态度是多么具有偶然性。我想你能明白为什么把安提诺斯称为同性恋并不能公正地体现其中发生的事情的复杂性。但与此同时，我认为这种——同样，这可能是我一厢情愿的想法。也许我过于浪漫了——
the sense of that there is love there i do find touching because it's very difficult to find anything like that by and large in the dynamics of kind of roman relationships like this so if people want to read more about this they can of course turn tom they can pre-order your book pax they can i know you're much too modest a man i am to promote it yourself so i'm going to do it for you i'm do the dirty work as it were so you can pre-order tom's book backs now next time on the rest is history we'll be talking about a man to whom this story meant a lot so a man who was really interested with the greeks with the idea of greek love and with the story of Antinous. And that is Oscar Wilde.
那种认为其中存在爱情的感觉，我确实觉得很感人，因为在罗马这种关系中，你很难在很大程度上找到类似的东西。所以如果人们想了解更多关于这的内容，他们当然可以去看看，汤姆，他们可以预订你的新书《帕克斯》（Pax）。他们可以。我知道你是一个太谦虚的人，不会亲自去宣传它，所以我来为你效劳。我来做这种脏活累活。所以你可以现在预订汤姆的书《帕克斯》。下期《历史的剩余》（The Rest is History），我们将谈论一个对这个故事意义重大的人——一个对希腊人、对希腊之爱的理念以及安提诺斯的故事非常感兴趣的人。那个人就是奥斯卡·王尔德（Oscar Wilde）。
So you said we've got a god and a martyr. You absolutely do, don't we? So we'll be talking about the trials of Oscar Wilde next time. Tom, on that bombshell, thank you very much. That was brilliant. Thank you. And we will see you all next time. Bye-bye.
所以你刚才说我们有了一个神和一个殉道者。你完全说对了，不是吗？所以我们下次将讨论奥斯卡·王尔德的审判。汤姆，在这个重磅炸弹之后，非常感谢你。这太精彩了。谢谢你。我们下次再见。再见。
Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的剩余》。想要获取独家单集、抢先收听、无广告体验以及加入我们的聊天社群，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。也就是 therestisentertainment.com。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。